hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and this is the Sony rx100 Mark 3 and
it's the best pocket camera ever made
now if that sounds familiar it's because
I said the same thing about the rx100
mark 2 hey what is up guys I'm KB HD
here and this is the best pocket camera
ever made thanks for watching so what
makes this new camera better than the
mark 2 well they've added a couple of
features they've made a few improvements
here and they're added a couple of
things that make it naturally a little
bit of a step up obviously it costs a
little bit more I'll have a link in the
description if you want to check this
out but basically it still fits in my
pocket and it's better than the mark 2
therefore it keeps the title of best
camera that I can fit in my pocket so
what are the improvements that make it
better than the mark 2 so number one new
viewfinder number two the LCD and number
three this new lens so the EVF the
electronic viewfinder is a new addition
it pops out of the top left side of the
camera when you want to use it and it
shows all the same controls and the same
information as the LCD would so if
you're shooting outside or in a really
bright environment where you can't quite
see that already gorgeous LCD you can
use that eyepiece and actually has a
proximity sensor to turn on and off when
you bring your eye up to it so it's
really impressive it looks good I don't
even know how Sony found the space
inside the camera to krema sting in the
first place but they did and it's not
any bigger than the last camera so one
thing to really keep an eye on is that
EVF now the only thing I don't like
about it is when I push the viewfinder
back in the camera to stop using it it
turns the whole camera off I kind of
wish they wouldn't do that I wish they
would let me continue using the camera
after I'm done using a viewfinder I
guess I should just spend an option in
the settings alright number two is the
LCD the rx100 mark one had a fixed LCD
on the back couldn't articulate it at
all the mark two had an LCD that you
could start to articulate a little bit
and move it around this mark three has
an LCD that can flip completely around
so you can see yourself for portrait
photos and videos I'm being nice I mean
selfies and you can take photos or
videos and all kinds of weird angles
thanks to the display being able to flip
around more than ever before and last
the third new thing is the new lens so
this camera has always had a great
answer that 20 megapixels sensor from
Sony but this mark 3 has a slightly
wider angle slightly faster lens still
super high quality Carl Zeiss glass so
that's awesome but now it's the
equivalent of a 24 to 70 millimeter lens
that goes from F 2.8 at 70 millimetres
to F 1.8 at 24 millimeter so it's a
little bit less reach you don't get
quite the same zoom as the mark 2 but
that is an insanely low aperture for
such a wide angle and it bests anything
sony has ever done in the past for both
on paper and in practice all this new
stuff has the new rx100 looking a bit
like a beast of a camera which it really
is kind of like a Swiss Army knife of
pocket imagery and everything else
though is really the same which is good
because it's got that same great battery
life same great build quality same great
materials same great image quality
dynamic range sharpness color same great
easy to understand Sony menu system and
interface same great ring around the
front which can be programmed to change
the aperture or whatever else you want
to change it can be changed focus but
that ring is actually pretty genius and
I'm surprised no one else has done it
yet same great pop-up flash that you can
articulate any way you want so you don't
have to flash directly on your subject
you can instead bounce the light off of
a wall or ceiling for a softer fill
effect same great NFC on the side as the
mark 2 so you can install that Sony
PlayMemories app on your phone and if
you have your phone with NFC you can
just tap your phone to the camera to
transfer your photos you just took it's
really handy if you just want to share a
quick photo you took on social media and
the photos and videos that it does take
are still awesome the autofocus is super
fast so you don't have to worry about
that it will nail focus every time and
then the photos are consistently really
sharp with you know nice dynamic range
pretty pleasing color reproduction just
like its older brothers it's also a
killer in low-light since the sensor is
closer to a DSLR size it's much bigger
than other pocket cameras and honestly
the photos you'll get out of this are
very similar to what you get out of
something like the Canon t5i or
similarly priced DSLR and it's kit lens
maybe even better since you get this
nice new Sony lens in this Carl Zeiss
glass now this camera will also be
awesome if you're a vlogger now I'm not
a vlogger but if you happen to shoot a
lot of front-facing video or selfie
portrait style video the wider angle
lens and the articulating LCD that lets
you see yourself is a huge plus so
that's something you're not going to get
on the mark 1 and mark 2 so this
combined with the awesome quality video
like I said the wider angle lens the
faster aperture the sharpness the great
codec the dynamic range and everything I
mean it's not the lightest camera in the
world but if you want to have the
highest quality vlogs in the business I
think this is easy choice now as much of
the video side that I like to focus on I
do take a lot of photos with this camera
and put I post them all over social
media Instagram Twitter Google+ even
Facebook sometimes and pretty much every
time there's someone asking hey that's a
pretty sharp photo what did you take
that with and a lot of times it's what
this there's usually a certain character
to the photos you take with a pocket
camera they're usually a lower
resolution they're usually a little bit
noisier I'd have smaller sensors they
don't do as well in low light colors
might not be quite as good as a more
expensive DSLR but at the end of the day
when you're comparing a pocket camera to
DSLRs instead of other pocket cameras
that's how you can tell that it's the
best pocket camera in the world it's
just that much better than all the rest
of the smaller cameras out there no one
get me wrong there are other small
cameras that don't fit in my pocket that
take really good photos I've been
playing with the Fuji x100s recently
it's not going to fit in my pocket it's
smaller than the SLR and it takes DSLR
like images so they're it's really
really good but it doesn't fit in my
pocket and that's why it doesn't get the
same price this could even make a great
starting youtuber camera if you're just
starting a YouTube channel and you're
looking to buy a camera that's going to
take awesome videos it has autofocus it
has great zoom it has great sharpness
it's not 4k it's still 1080p video but
it has a great codec it has a 60 frames
per second video 30 frames per second
video 24 frames per second video 720p
120 frames per second video it's loaded
with features and I would actually say
go grab mark 2 or Mark 3 to start a
YouTube channel
instead of a DSLR and you'll learn a lot
about still the kind of shooting we'll
do later down the road if you switch to
a DSLR but there are so many features
here that remind me of a DSLR so I'm
going on about it enough this is
obviously one of my thing
cameras and I do take it with me all
over the place I'll have a link below if
you want to check it out I'll also have
a link to the mark 2 and the mark 1 like
I said because those tend to be lower
priced than the mark 3 but hey this
could be your steal on Black Friday or
something like that this could easily be
an awesome gift or something you want to
check out like I said if you're starting
a channel or something so the links are
below thank you for watching hope you
enjoyed and if you did feel free to
leave a thumbs up below and I'll talk to
you guys in the next video peace